وعن هذا الاحتفال الضخم وكواليس تغطيه
العربيه ووسائل الاعلام العالميه ينضم
الينا من الرياض مراسلنا عبد المحسن
الحربي اهلا بك عبد المحسن بدايه سنبدا
بالقصه كيف بلشت عندما العربيه انفردت
بالخبر
اعلان عن انضمام كريستيانو رونالدو لنادي
النصر خبرنا عن تفاعل الناس مع هذا الخبر
بالبدايه
العربيه
حتى ان يعلن نادي النصر وكله الاستعداد
وقتها في القيام بهذه التغطيه وبدانا
تغطيه قبل ان يعلن همم النصر همم
التوقيع الرسمي مع كريستيانو ذهبت انا
للشارع اسال الناس اثناء الهواء بعض منهم
كان مصدوم بعض منهم كان غير مصدق بعض منهم
كان حتى يكذب الخبر
حتى انا شخصيا يعني كنت اقول همم نحن طبعا
فرضنا بالخبر ونحن همم لدينا الخبر الاكيد
ولكن للجمهور لم يكن يصدق حتى كلامي اثناء
سؤالي لهم كانوا يتكلمون في العموميات
الكل كان غير مصدق في لحظتها فكانت لحظه
تاريخيه وظهورنا في اللايف قبل الاعلان
الرسمي لنادي النصر كان صدمه حتى على
الجما همم وهم بالفعل بداوا بتداول
الاخبار بعد ان ظهر الخبر على قناه
العربيه وهمم بدؤوا بالفعل ب- اا تداوله
بشكل واسع وبنقاشه وبانتظار التاكيد
الرسمي من نادي النصر في كانت لحظات
التاريخيه قبل الاعلان الرسمي
الاعلاميه العالميه والعربيه لهذا الحدث
على المواقف الطريف
في رونالدو
مع الكواليس يعني
في التغطيه كانت التغطيه ليست على المستوى
الاعلام السعودي او الاقليميه او حتى
العربي كانت تغطيه دوليه بكل ما تعني
الكلمه الانظار العالم كلها كانت متجهه
الى الرياض فبالتالي كان تعاطي مع هذا
الخبر همم ليس فقط للمشاهد المحلي او
المشجع عن النصراوي المحلي المهتم في كره
القدم انما كان الكل يتابعك عبر ال همم
عبر القنوات عبر وسائل الاعلام المختلفه
وحتى يتناولون الفيديوهات التي همم تقوم
بها او تؤديها فبالتالي كان كانت التغطيه
مختلفه وكان ايضا وجود وسائل الاعلام
الدوليه في كل مكان في المتجر في الشارع
في متجر نادي النصر في الشارع وحوالي
النادي ايضا كان وجود كريستيانو رونالدو
يوم الامس في الملعب همم
العالم مستمره لكل غير مصدق لبعض كان يريد
وكمان احدهم ياخد سيلفي معه
وحدا كمان جرب ياخذ سلفي معه
ايضا اعلاميين صينيين يحاولون يلتقطون على
المرتبه
معكم
في الجانب الايمن معتقدا ان التصوير
اخذ راحتي على الاقل مع هذا الاسطوره
العالمي ولكن تفاجات بين الصوره كانت
مقوله لايف وزملاء على طول ارسلوا لي في
الواتساب انه همم خلي كريستيانو يروح
ويكمل الحفله ما احنا فاضيين انك انت
عن التيشيرت اللي حصلت عليها كمان خبرنا
في المتجر الرسمي كانت الطوابير الانتظار
لثلاثه ايام
وكان الحصول على هذا التيشيرت صعب جدا
فبالتالي انك تحصل على التيشيرت رونالدو
في الوقت هذا يعني هذه خطوه لا لا احد
يستطيع ان همم ان يحصل عليها ولكن انا
للامانه لم احصل على هذا التيشيرت والحظ
وليست لديه انما اخذته وتصورت معه ورجعت
لصاحبه وحنضمي للطبابير حتى احصل على على
التيشيرت من المتجر الرسمي طيب
تفاعل رونالدو مع الاعلاميين السعوديين
والاعلام بشكل عام كيف كان باختصار
التفاعل في المؤتمر الصحفي كريستيانو
في المؤتمر الصحفي بعض الاعلاميين كان
يقوم بترديد ايضا سواء كان السعوديين او
حتى من من الخارج بترديد حركه كريستيانو
الشهيره سي فكان مصدوم اثناء وجود هذا
المؤتمر وينظر باستغراب
وفرحه ايضا
لكريستيانو ايضا كان بعض الاشخاص كانوا
يقولوا لا رونالدو اي لاف يو فبالتالي
كريستيانو اا تفاجا وتوقف قليلا وقام ينظر
الى همم هؤلاء الاعلاميين في الحقيقه كل
ما حدث امس يوم تاريخ تاريخ ما يكون
بالحلم ان يكون كريستيانو ليس زياره خاطفه
انما معنا في الرياض وفي فريق النصر
ومستمر ان شاء الله الى همم الى سنتين
بحسب عقده
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]